do you want to know the secrets
Architects use to dramatically lower
energy bills for their clients well
you're in for a treat because we're
about to discover not just one not two
but a whopping nine powerful strategies
from harnessing natural light to
unlocking those elusive government
rebates and even simple yet effective
home upgrades that can slash your bills
in half we've got it all covered you see
for the past decade I've practice as an
architect right here in Western
Australia designing sustainable
multi-million dollar homes day in day
out I've rolled up my sleeves learned
the ropes and put every single one of
these strategies to the test stick
around to the end because what most
people tell you that will save you money
will actually result in you burning
through piles of cash my peers will
often charge a small fortune for these
insights and yet I'm giving them to you
absolutely free in the hope you use this
information to make a significant change
to your life improving it forever let's
kick off with something relatively
straightforward a revelation for you the
average fridge accounts for whopping 13%
of your home's energy consumption it's a
vital point to emphasize that selecting
the right appliances for your home is an
absolute priority this is precisely why
Architects charge to handpick everything
inside a client's home the these
selections pay for themselves in no time
at all you need to think of your
appliances as the heartbeat of your home
just as a healthy heart ensures a long
and vibrant life opting for energy
efficient appliances ensures a thriving
home with lower bills since we're
speaking of fridges let's take a Ganda
at this $900 fridge sporting an average
Three Star Energy rating it will set you
back around
$340 per year to operate now let's
compare that to this $1,000 fridge it's
a stellar fstar energy rating Appliance
it sips a mere $82 a year to run here's
where the magic happens by choosing the
higher rated fridge you're looking at
$158 saving in your first Year's Energy
bill and it keeps giving you pocket an
extra
$258 in savings every year afterwards
all for a modest upgrade of $100 this is
one of those cases where you're thanks
you over and over again so the choice is
clear invest a little bit more up front
and watch your savings grow year after
year now let's dive a bit deeper into
maximizing your savings you've probably
heard the buzzword in architecture solar
passive design there's a good reason for
this hype picture your home as a
sunflower always turning to face the sun
your living area should do the same it
should be designed to capture as much
natural light as possible it's like your
home's very own sunflower following the
sunlight for the central glow now
consider this you've got 10 lights in
your living area and let's even be
generous and assume they're all super
efficient LEDs if we were to run all of
these lights for 12 hours a day
throughout the entire year you'd be fing
out a whopping
$657 why because your home lacks the
blessing of natural light now let's
switch things up a little bit imagine
the sun beaming into the same room for 8
out of those 12 hours leaving you with
Just 4 hours of artificial light
throughout the day that's a mere
$219 for the entire year giving you a
delightful saving of
$438 and for those that are curious
about my math I'm using a rate of $3
cents per kilowatt hour which is pretty
standard for most households here in
Australia in this example the savings
can be as simple as letting the sun do
its job and as the old saying goes let
there be light now let's take a closer
look at an often overlooked culprit your
windows did you know that your windows
are one of the worst performing elevates
of your entire home they're like an open
Gateway letting precious heat Escape
into the winter and unwanted heat invade
your living room space during those
scorching summer months whether you like
it or not they're going to do it your
windows are ke to the eyes of your home
but having single glazing is like
wearing a flimsy pair of sunglasses on a
blazing hot day it's time for an upgrade
just like you should throw out those
cheap glasses and Dawn a pair of
high-end polarized Shades the industry's
standard choice in Australia for decades
has been single glazing for reasons only
known to the universe and it is time for
a change let's put it into perspective
double glazing may be a bit more of an
investment about 50% more to be precise
but the difference it makes is profound
and quick to recoup while it's a bit
harder to quantify the exact numbers
double glazing can reduce your heat gain
and loss by approximately 30%
translating into a substantial 30% cut
in your heating and cooling bills this
upgrade might take a little bit of time
to pay off but the comfort and the
savings it brings will be worth it in no
time now if you're ready to embark on
your sustainable architectural design
Journey it all begins with a
well-crafted project brief having spent
over a decade in the world of
architecture I've witnessed the power of
clear and concise briefs without one the
project can lose direction and end up
costing so much more than it should
that's why I've introduced the client's
DIY architectural brief a userfriendly
template designed for you to
effortlessly Define your vision to your
architect yes even if it's not me this
brief will not only guide your project
but it will also set your project apart
into something truly exceptional please
don't leave your architectural dreamed
chance head over to the website linked
down below and secure your DIY brief
today plus as a token of my appreciation
for sticking around this long use the
coupon code energy to enjoy a generous
50% discount on your DIY brief let's
move on when it comes to Energy
Solutions batteries have been hailed as
the future or at least a promising
alternative Source but let's di into the
controversy without getting caught up in
Net Zero aspirations our Focus here is
strictly Financial you see household
batteries have been a bit of a financial
Quirk that doesn't quite align with
their potential if we compare them to
their green counterpart Standalone solar
panel systems these solar panel systems
boast a relatively Snappy payback period
typically ranging anywhere from 3 to 6
years that's impressive considering
their warranties often span a decade and
their lifespan can stretch over 25 years
if you're at home during the day the
verdict is clear Go Solar and start
saving now don't procrastinate time is
money and these panels can become your
power garden cultivating energy as
efficiently as a well- tendered Garden
yields fresh produce now let's talk
about the elephant in the room batteries
they're the juicy ripe fruit you're
tempted to pick because they represent
the future of energy storage however the
reality is a little bit different you
see batteries have a payback period
stretching from 10 to 13 years their
warranty usually spans a decade and
their expected lifespan Falls anywhere
between 5 and 15 years so here's the
catch you'll likely find yourself in a
NeverEnding Loop of replacing batteries
before you've ever paid them off
batteries may be the future but for now
they're like an unripened fruit they
might seem promising but they're just
not worth the wait in terms of financial
return stick with the solar panels for
now and enjoy the immediate savings if
you find yourself in a tight Financial
spot there is a good chance your
government offers some form of energy
rebate to assist you during challenging
times these rebates come in various
shapes and sizes they could be a direct
Financial relief or they might involve
some sort of customized energy plan that
tweaks your on Peak and off peak rates
everyone encounters financial hardship
at some point in their lives so don't
hesitate to explore the assistance
options available to you if by any
chance your government isn't extending a
helping hand don't forget that the banks
often provide hardship considerations
for hom loans ensuring you don't face
default and can manage your Rising
energy costs more effectively it's like
having a safety net to really help you
through the financial roller coaster
which will hopefully mean you're going
to be able to use hot water in your very
own home now choosing the right heating
system is akin to selecting your
preferred way of warming up on a chil
Windle morning it's all about finding
the perfect balance between comfort and
cost so here's a quick breakdown of your
options instant natural gas you can
think of it as a cozy Plush Blanket that
wraps you with warmth almost instantly
however like a luxurious blanket it
comes with a high price tag about $300
per year to operate for a $2,000 system
instant electric on the other hand this
is like a thick warm sweater with some
holes not as quick to warm you up cheap
but also needs replacing coming in at
around
$635 per year for $1,000 system finally
we have a heat pump imagine this as an
expensive bottomless cup of tea that
gently warms you from the inside costing
roughly $250 a year to operate but the
system will set you back $4,000 choosing
the best options depends on factors like
availability and whether you have solar
panels or not so it's a bit like
deciding whether whether you reach for
that cozy blanket or the trusty sweater
or potentially even a soothing cup of
tea to start your day if we stick with
these great metaphors for a second and
think of your home as a treasure chest
filled with warmth and comfort but
sometimes a sneaky pirate in the form of
drafts tries to steal your precious
Treasures these drafts are essentially
like unwanted Intruders attempting to
plunder through your cozy Haven weather
strips can act as a sturdy lock that
keeps these Pirates out safeguarding
your treasure chest of comfort they are
your trusty protectors Against The
Unwanted cold air that creeps into your
home the best part weather strips are
affordable and a breeze to install just
peel stick and you're done you can find
them at your local hardware store this
weekend or you can check the description
down below for an Amazon link by sealing
every air League you're not only
maintaining your Treasures security but
you're also potentially saving around
$50 a year it may not seem like an
astronomical sum but it's certainly
enough to keep those drafts a bay moving
on to Smart blinds these are like your
home's personal assistant they know when
it's time to let the gentle Morning Sun
in and when to Shield you from the harsh
afternoon Rays creating the perfect
Ambience so let's talk about curtains
for a moment did you know they're not
just for blocking light and adding A
Touch of Elegance to your home heavy
curtains that close at night and open in
the morning can play a crucial role Ro
in reducing heat loss during colder
months and they can prevent heat gain on
those scorching days as well they act as
natural insulators lessening the burden
on your heating and cooling systems
which translates to potential Savings of
around 10% but here's the modern twist
curtains can be automated this
Innovation provides added convenience
allowing you to customize your curtain
settings based on the time of day it's
like having your curtains respond to
your specific needs providing both f
financial and comfort benefits plus
we're all busy individuals who sometimes
forget to adjust our blinds I know this
is definitely me smart curtains
eliminate human error and increase the
chances of significant energy cost
savings so consider them as your homes
efficient helper managing the perfect
lighting conditions and contributing to
a more sustainable and economical
lifestyle finally we move on to proper
Landscaping which is like natural armor
for your home just like a wears a suit
of armor for protection a well plushed
tree and vegetation Shield your home
from excessive Heating and Cooling costs
if we delve into the fascinating world
of landscaping nobody would have thought
that annoying tree in the front of your
house the one that drops leaves in the
winter is actually saving you money
right well proper landscape can work
Wonders by providing natural shading to
your entire home leading to an average
annual saving of around $100 in cooling
costs trees and vegetation thoughtfully
placed around your property act as a
shield against direct sunlight
preventing excessive heat from
penetrating your home during the war
months and when those leads shed it
allows that winter warmth to actually
come into the home when you need it most
this eco-friendly approach not only
contributes to Energy savings but it
also enhances the Aesthetics of your
property it's a win-win situation except
you know you have to clean up those
leaves anyway that's all from me te if
you enjoyed this video make sure you
smash that subscribe button down below
for more weekly
content